- THE CITY OF BROTHERLY LOVE.
- WELCOME TO THE 'BURGH.
- WITH TWO EVEN BIGGER
PERSONALITIES.
- I'M MURPH,
OWNER AND OPERATOR
SOUTH PHILLY MURPH'S
PAWN SHOP ON SOUTH STREET.
HERE IN PHILLY,
I GOT ALL THE BUSINESS
AND WOMEN I CAN HANDLE.
[tires screech]
- IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING STEELERS,
PIRATES, PENGUINS,
WE GOT ALL THAT CRAP
DOWN AT DON'S PAWN.
OH, THAT'S GOOD AS HELL.
WELCOME...
- WELCOME...
TO PAWNSYLVANIA.
- YOU'RE COMING BY TOMORROW
TO PICK UP THEM LAUNDRIES,
AREN'T YOU, ANYWAY?
- OH, YEAH, I GOTTA GET
THEM LAUNDRIES.
[phone ringing]
- HELLO?
- MURPH. DON.
- WHAT'S UP, DON?
YOU WANT ADVICE
ON HOW TO WIN
A WORLD SERIES?
- PBBBT. NO, I'M CALLING
TO GIVE YOU ADVICE
ON HOW TO WIN ONE SUPER BOWL...
EVER.
- I GOT A PAWN SHOP
TO RUN HERE, DON.
- OH, YEAH, YEAH, I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
LISTEN, JAGGOFF,
I GOT A WHOLE TREASURE TROVE
OF PHILLY MAGAZINES, OKAY?
ONE OF 'EM'S GOT A PICTURE
OF DARREN DAULTON IN A TUX
EATING A HOTDOG.
- THAT ONE WHERE HE GOT
THE MUSTARD ON HIS FACE?
- YEAH, THAT'S THE ONE.
- OH, THAT WOULD MOVE HERE
FOR SURE.
[baseball music]
NOW THAT YOU MENTION IT,
I GET THEM SLACKS WORN
BY JEAN CLAUDE VAN DAMME
IN THAT MOVIE SUDDEN DEATH.
[exciting music]
- DOUBLE YOI!
A PITTSBURGH CLASSIC.
- EVERY PIECE OF [bleep]'S
A CLASSIC IN PITTSBURGH.
- [laughs]
- WELL, I GOT SOMETHING
I COULD SELL THERE.
YOU GOT SOMETHING
YOU COULD SELL HERE.
- YEAH? WHAT OF IT?
- [whispers]
SWAP SHOPS.
- DON, I JUST HAD
A HOME RUN IDEA.
WHY DON'T WE SWAP SHOPS?
- SOUNDS GOOD.
POOKIE?
- YEAH.
- I'M PHILLY-BOUND.
WILL YOU PACK ME
A CHIP-CHOP HAM SANDWICH?